is this friendship an abomination in the
eyes of the law what kind of sorcerer
Supreme in a reformed super villain find
genuine connection
law wastes no time in utilizing the vast
Powerhouse that is a Marvel Cinematic
Universe throughout the nine episode
series She-Hulk brings in several
characters and references from the MCU
placing them directly in the path of the
fourth wall breaking Jennifer Walters
after the first episode explored the
relationship between Jen and her cousin
Bruce Banner fans got a chance to see
sorcerer Supreme wonk Emil Blonsky
Daredevil and even several references to
new Asgard Thor and the love life of
Captain America in other words She-Hulk
is acutely aware of his position in a
greater narrative with the finale of
She-Hulk several new elements have been
introduced that could be laying the
groundwork for future MCU movies and TV
series perhaps the greatest shocker in
shihong though is the introduction of
Hulk's son scar which some fans believe
may be setting up a World War Hulk movie
of course in the Marvel tradition the
finale features a post-credits scene
which raises particular questions about
the future of some fun favorite
characters although She-Hulk attorney at
law sets up a battle among She-Hulk Hulk
Abomination a transformed Todd Phelps
and Titania She-Hulk uses her ability to
break the fourth wall and enters into
our reality where she demands to see
Kevin which is a direct call out to
Marvel Studios honcho Kevin feige after
finding out that Kevin is actually an
artificial intelligence she calls for
changes that will hold people
accountable for their actions this
causes the Brewing epic battle to be
completely tossed out and instead both
Todd and Emile are arrested Todd for
hacking Jen's computer and phone and a
meal for breaking the terms of his
parole considering Emile blonsky's new
outlook on life and general Zen demeanor
he accepts his responsibility and his
punishment of 10 years in prison however
the end credit stinger and the She-Hulk
finale shows Wanga once again using his
sling ring to open a portal into a meals
Glass Prison one reason for Wong's
continuing efforts to break Emile
Blonsky out of prison and could be that
Wong and Blonsky are actually friends in
the third episode one appears on behalf
of Blonsky during his parole hearing the
authorities want to know why and how
Blonsky escaped and Wang explains that
he did it and even though Wong offered
Blonsky Sanctuary blonski turned this
offer down in order to show that he's
reformed at this point the authorities
points out that Wong committed a crime
by letting Blonsky Go free for a time
you realize that you've just admitted to
facilitating a prisoner escape which is
a crime
Wong may consider a meal Blonsky an
actual friend and since Blonsky is only
being sent back to prison for a parole
violation Wong couldn't let him lose a
decade of his life however there could
be another reason why Wong decided to
Spring Blonsky again prior to She-Hulk
the Abominations last MCU appearance
came with a cameo in Xiang Chi and the
legend of the ten rings as She-Hulk
reveals the movie's cage fight between
Wong and Abomination was part of Wong's
training Wong required a worthy Foe and
Abomination happened to fit the bill
there's no animosity between the two as
highlighted by She-Hulk and its finale
scene so it could be that Wong is simply
thankful for Emil's efforts in this
department or it could be that wonk has
the intention of using abomination in
the training of other students he could
also be making good on his original
offer of sanctuary because it's probably
hard to get somebody extradited from
Karma Taj or perhaps there's even a
chance for a future TV show centered on
Wong and his who's who of Super Friends
for his part Benedict Wong has made made
it clear he loves playing the character
he told The Hollywood Reporter I'm just
enjoying playing this role and where it
takes me in every single kind of project
that they invite me to be involved in it
just pulls away another layer of the
onion you know you get to find a little
bit more about the eccentricities of the
sorcerer Supreme now Marvel fans just
need to sit back breathe deep and await
the next appearance of the Abomination
and the Sorcerer Supreme
[Music]